[Music]
[Applause]
what's up guys I'm be showing you a
moneymaking method that involves making
crystal keys and so what we're going to
do we're going to buy Loop half of keys
and tooth half of keys and we're going
to put them together to make the Crystal
Key we're going to buy the loop half and
the tooth half for the highest price and
then sell it for the lowest price so we
can get the margins and then we're going
to buy it for slightly above the lowest
price PR to get the best price possible
and then we're going to put the keys
together and we're going to sell them as
a crystal key and right now I think the
crystal key is going for about 2k more
and as you can see they're already
selling so I'll wait when they come back
okay they're back and now I'm going to
collect
them I'm going to put them in the
bank and then take them
out put the coins in there take out 14
of each cuz 28 inventory
spaces and then all you do is you put
them together like
this and I'm going to go ahead and time
this and tell you guys how long it takes
and then sell
them all right I'm
done and it took about a minute 48 so
we'll go ahead and round that to 2
minutes so it took two minutes to make
to make 87 of
them and let's check how much we sold
them for the other
time
31116 write that down so I don't
remember 3116 I typed that wrong a
well 311
six all right we'll put them in and
we'll see how long it takes to
sell all right they
sold took a while to S sell but they
eventually did sell and so let's go
ahead and do the
math so the
2707 092 that I
made
minus the
1663 2
66 but I bought the tooths for and now
minus the loop
halves all right 205k 929 time the 30
minutes because it took 2 minutes wow
okay 6 M an hour let's go ahead and do
this again with 100 keys and let's see
what
happens so I bought 100 more of them for
different
prices take out 14 of each just like
last
time and we'll go ahead and put them
together and we'll time it again so we
can get an accurate reading to make sure
2 minutes wasn't a
fluke all right we're done and it took
about two minutes
again then we have 100 of
them um it's very important that you
check the margins buy them buy high sell
low and then sell them for the highest
price and buy them for the lowest price
if that makes
sense so we're going to go ahead and buy
one so they're selling
for about 30k so we'll sell them a
little bit below that
$2999 and I'll come back when they
sell all right guys I had to put them in
for a a little bit lower because they
weren't selling so now we'll go ahead
and see how much they sell for okay they
sold for
29789 so let's do the
math so
minus what I bought them for 1711 Z
now minus what I bought the other ones
for and now we need a minus because I
bought two of them on top of that to get
the margins so I got to minus
30k and then minus 30k again and then 60
divided by two is 30 so we're going to
times it by
30 okay so if you do this hourly you can
make 10.7 mil that is insane guys all
right stay tuned for my next video guys
if you can keep a secret